[Music]
when we started working on the concept
art for horizon zero dawn it was almost
as if a boy is a character kind of
jumped out of the concert dog he was the
ideal vessel I felt to explore his world
to unravel some of these great mysteries
years before we had her in the way that
she is now in the game praying won't
save us we have to find the killers such
a massive long ongoing iterative process
I would say finally when all the
elements came together you felt duck
yeah this is her to say
I think we've created and designed at
the very strong character that hopefully
we'll see a lot more
I think it's really hard to design an
iconic character you can hope for it but
it's not something like okay that's it
put a stamp on it its iconic now there
are people even within this building who
are they were feeling like is like oh
how do we try to you know get something
that's like to ninety percent of Nathan
Drake looking at the kill zone games we
were kind of doing it the wrong way
around with eloy we had a protagonist
now that is as strong as iconic
character as the hell gasps were as
antagonist there's so many you think of
four layers also to designing a
character she's this combination of
voice actress there's the face there's
the hair we have the costume there's how
she moves there's the dialogue that also
adds to her character you can help or
you can get out of my way it's nice
after so many years to have it out there
and hear people what they think about it
everything like
it's been super invigorating seeing the
the immediate response to a law as a
character I mean in the cosplay scene
there's been such a huge interest in
finding out more who she is it's very
clear that at least for these people
alloy is already an iconic character to
get that confirmation that we we
actually touch upon something that's
that's relevant and people respond to it
very positively that's hugely hugely
positive for the team you come a long
way since the sitter to Lin LOI who are
you an interested pudding a large part
of what mater is the narrative itself
baby that started shaping her as an
identity as a character so ultimately
whether we give a red hair or blonde
hair or dark hair isn't really that's
important it's more that the character
itself becomes I going
I don't think that there's anybody
working at guerrilla games who hasn't
fallen in love with a boy I mean for us
she has become someone who feels like a
real person the nice thing about our
story the way that is written is that
she's emerging from the area that she's
lived her whole life and going out into
the big world along with you so
everything is just as into her as it is
to you and you feel a real resonance
with character that way
eloy is I think a very appealing
character the way she looks but more
importantly the stuff she can do she's
super agile she's quick she's very
crafty she's very strategic she's a
great person a great companion through
except to explore the world of horizons
or the dog the trail leads
I will go ps4 for the players